[Music]
gasps he was like a thousand years ago I
fought my way out of that cave became
Iron Man
[Music]
we lost I loved you UNMISS had no more
surprises but I was really hoping to
pull off one last one
the world has changed
none of us
what we can do is our best and sometimes
the best we can do
[Applause]
[Music]
I see all these people died
I can tell him everybody there should
mean Wang
someday bananas
[Music]
even if there's a small chance
we owe this
everyone who's not in this room to try
[Music]
we will
whatever it takes
[Music]
Reverend Tex
takes
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Music]
I like this one
[Applause]
some people move on but about us
not us
[Music]
stay huh
hey miss Ponce if you find this
recording don't feel better about this
part of the journey use the end
[Music]
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun that sounds food and water went
out four days ago
officers will run out tomorrow morning
I've been when I drift off I will dream
about him it's always you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a nose did exactly what he said he was
gonna do he wiped out 50% of all living
creatures
we lost all of us
Plus friends who lost family
you lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany that got really big it's just an
old message I know you know that that's
me can you buzz me in
[Music]